[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Lorraine lubanza au
Trice du livre Barry I Love You aux
éditions Spinell bonjour bonjour on va
parler de votre livre dans quelques
instants en 2021 vous êtes diplômé d'un
master en communication et stratégie
sociale média vous avez également fait
un séjour professionnel en Côte d'Ivoire
rien ne laisse paraître finalement avec
ces informations que vous aimez écrire
et pourtant vous avez sorti un premier
roman alors comment vous est venu le
goût de l'écriture alors c'est
totalement ça donc moi ça fait déjà
depuis que je suis petite que j'aime
écrire donc c'est vrai que c'était
personnel il y avait vraiment que mes
proches donc mes parents et mes soeurs
qui savaient ma passion pour l'écriture
donc j'avais écrit des poèmes une
histoire également quand j'étais petite
je devais avoir 7-8 ans et je me
souviens encore d'ailleurs de cette
histoire là c'était vraiment le côté si
vous voulez imaginaire que que j'aime
dans l'écriture du fait qu'on peut
vraiment inventer son monde qu'on peut
tout dire qu'on peut décider que le ciel
soit rouge dans notre histoire dans
notre histoire pardon tant qu'on arrive
à emmener le lecteur c'est le principal
tant qu'on arrive à faire plonger
justement notre notre public dans
l'histoire et que ce soit cohérent bah
c'est le principal et c'est ça qui me
c'est cette imaginaire finalement que
vous vouliez pousser votre imaginaire
que vous vouliez écrire et faire
partager c'est ça alors d'un intérêt
donc depuis de votre plus jeune âge vous
vous êtes donc finalement lancé dans
l'écriture de votre premier roman
pendant vos études qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé justement à vous dire c'est le
moment de se lancer mais c'est la
rencontre avec Barry donc je l'ai connu
par le biais d'une association scolaire
donc l'association
permettait justement de participer à
diverses missions et donc là c'était de
donner des cours de français à des
migrants donc on s'est rencontré à ce
moment là et il m'a raconté son histoire
et je l'ai trouvé tellement touchante
que je me suis dit que je pouvais pas
garder cette information là pour moi et
qu'il fallait que j'en fasse quelque
chose justement Barry I Love You c'est
donc avant tout une histoire une
histoire vraie une histoire avec une
rencontre quel est le résumé de votre de
votre roman et quel est l'histoire
finalement de Barry alors c'est des
jeunes qui participent à une
manifestation donc tout a été programmé
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est une
manifestation pacifique
il s'y rendent et la police et l'armée
également intervient et il déclare
qu'ils ont essayé de tuer le président
donc les jeunes ne comprennent pas Barry
fait partie bien entendu des
manifestants et il s'enfuit il a été
annoncé comme étant le commanditaire de
cette attaque donc lui c'est une
injustice il sait que c'est faux et il
est quand même obligé de fuir parce que
ça apporte atteinte à sa vie donc une
course-poursuite s'ensuit et on suit un
peu justement tout le cheminement de la
vie de bar donc Barry est une personne
qui existe réellement est-ce que vous
avez tout de même amplifié certaines
choses oui parce que je voulais vraiment
pouvoir justement ajouter ma pâte à
l'écriture je voulais vraiment pouvoir
également ajouter ce défait qui disons
me sont assez
assez
comment dire personnel qui me touche
c'est ça et je voulais également me
servir de l'histoire de Barry parce
qu'il a connu une injustice il a subi
une injustice et moi dans ce qui me
touche justement c'est ces choses qui
arrivent à ces personnes là qui sont pas
entendues ces personnes qui perdent leur
voix et qui sont pas considérés donc je
voulais vraiment me servir de ce sujet
là pour justement
est-ce qu'il vous a ce qu'il vous a un
peu aidé à écrire ou en tout cas et ce
qui vous a accompagné dans cette
écriture alors pas du tout parce qu'il
était pas au courant premièrement je
l'ai vraiment fait de mon côté parce que
justement je voulais pas qu'il me donne
de détails je l'ai gardé cette voilà
c'est parti de créativité d'imagination
que je pouvais ajouter à l'histoire et
c'est quand je l'ai fini que je l'ai
informé et heureusement il a bien pris
alors pourquoi écrire justement sur sur
l'histoire de de cette étudiante et ce
qu'avant de vouloir toucher les lecteurs
vous avez été vous-même sensible au
passé de du fameux Barry c'est ça c'est
exactement ça ça son histoire m'a
vraiment chamboulé donc pour la petite
histoire on a pris le métro ensemble et
c'est vraiment pendant ce trajet de
métro qui m'a raconté son histoire et en
sortant j'arrêtais pas d'y penser et je
me disais mais je peux pas garder cette
histoire là pour moi je dois vraiment en
faire quelque chose et dès le lendemain
j'ai commencé à écrire j'ai commencé
déjà à taper les mots et c'est venu au
fur et à mesure et je me suis dit moi je
vais la sortir quelque chose le plus
gros de cette histoire en tout cas ce
qui vous a motivé c'est cette injustice
qui a vécu qu'a vécu cette cette
étudiant est-ce qu'il y a donc un
message finalement à faire passer à
travers votre œuvre un peu disons que il
y a des personnes qui ne sont pas
entendues et qui
justement un des méfaits des problèmes
et on les considère pas et je pense que
c'est quand même important aussi de se
dire qu'ils ont une voix et qu'ils ont
une parole et que parce que dans
l'histoire c'est un régime qui en veut
un Barry c'est un tout un gouvernement
et généralement on a tendance à
considérer disons à la parole est plus
forte de ce qui sont plus nombreux de
ceux qui ont un statut et on considère
pas ce qu'on qui n'ont peut-être pas de
statut ou qui sont voilà un peu moins
bien vu disons dans la société et je
pense que c'est important aussi qu'ils
aient leur moi et dire et de pouvoir
parler d'eux alors justement quel est le
le caractère de cette étudiant qui qui
fuit je l'ai voulu assez proche du pari
que je connais donc c'est vraiment un
étudiant simple voilà il n'avait pas
d'histoire avant il avait sa famille il
faisait ses études c'est vraiment une
personne lambda et il lui arrivait cette
histoire là et il est devenu un paria
donc voilà j'ai vraiment voulu rester
simple et Barry n'est bien entendu pas
le seul personnage du du roman d'autres
personnages sont importants comme Zoé
admir linetta ou encore aimer quelles
sont les particularités de ces
personnages alors si on prend l'inetta
j'ai vraiment voulu représenter
représenter le côté un peu maternel
d'une mère qui n'a pas eu d'enfants mais
qui veut quand même aider qui a eu un
lien avec le gouvernement mais qui sait
que ce qu'elle a fait n'était pas
forcément correct et qui veut se
rattraper
aimer donc le chef des armées lui c'est
vraiment le statut justement de ce
régime quelqu'un très important mais
quand on y regarde bien dans l'histoire
c'est pas la personne la plus
intelligente et justement j'ai voulu un
peu représenter cet homme de pouvoir qui
au contraire en fait finalement
n'a pas la connaissance mais comme c'est
quelqu'un de très important il est
respecté auprès de la société
auteurs et autrice sont ouvertement
engagés à travers leurs œuvres ils
dénonce finalement ce que vous faites à
travers la dénonciation de l'injustice
est-ce que votre objectif c'est
justement d'être reconnu comme une
autrice engagée après je me dis qu'on
est un peu tous engagé quand on a
justement je pense qu'on a tous une
cause qu'on défend c'est vrai que moi
l'écriture comme c'est quelque chose que
j'aime bien ben j'ai envie aussi de m'en
servir pour faire passer un message ça
c'est totalement vrai mais je pense
qu'au fond on l'est tous un peu donc on
peut le dire on peut le dire mais tant
qu'on a une cause à défendre pour moi on
est tous un peu engagés en quelque chose
vous l'avez dit en début d'émission vous
aimez surtout l'imaginaire et c'est
surtout ça qui vous a qui vous a permis
d'écrire et qui vous a permis de
d'évoluer justement dans dans l'écriture
vous avez modifié finalement un petit
peu l'effet réel pour que ça soit
vraiment une une belle histoire on va
dire malgré enfin teintée d'injustice
etc est-ce que on retrouve quand même un
petit peu d'imaginaire dans votre dans
votre livre est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qui sortent parfois un peu de
l'ordinaire du réel
plus ou moins c'est vrai que par exemple
simplifié Barry dans la vraie vie n'a
pas essayé d'assassiner le Président
c'est important par exemple exactement
je préfère le préciser mais encore une
fois oui parce que
Barry dans l'histoire qui ne m'a raconté
donc le temps d'un trajet de métro il y
avait pas tous les détails il m'a parlé
des points principaux du fait qu'il a dû
fuir du fait qu'il a subi également
disons un travail forcé il est vraiment
rentré dans une sorte de prison pour
migrants mais encore une fois oui il y a
des détails qui sont amplifiés mais en
même temps j'ai envie de dire que il y a
des choses aussi sur lesquelles je me
suis renseignée par exemple pour la
prison pour migrants où il y a des faits
qui sont très dures qui sont arrivés et
que j'ai quand même voulu dépeindre dans
le livre parce que ça me semble quand
même important de ça de faire connaître
qui a des choses quand même dans ce
monde qui se passent qui sont inhumaines
mais que certains subissent
finalement de du réel on parfois dans
quelque chose de très fantasmé voilà
justement est-ce que vous souhaitez
continuer à écrire des romans peut-être
une
j'aimerais bien oui sur un des
personnages donc Zoé j'aimerais bien
également faire une suite
également repartir un peu sur les
l'avant disons manifestation et ce qui
se passait dans le pays également et
après complètement sortir du registre
aussi et comment était possible à
publication justement de Barry I Love
You quelles ont été les étapes après
l'écriture de ce roman alors j'ai je me
suis entourée donc d'une relais crise
professionnelle parce que je voulais
absolument avoir un livre disons voilà
avec une pâte littéraire qui s'y prête
parce que forcément quand nous on écrit
avec notre écriture il y a peut-être des
choses aussi qu'on sait pas et je suis
pas encore je suis encore débutante dans
le domaine donc c'est important d'avoir
un avis extérieur donc elle m'a beaucoup
aidé dans la réécriture du livre et
ensuite j'ai commencé mes démarches dans
la recherche d'une maison d'édition
alors on peut retrouver donc Barry I
Love You aux éditions spinel qui est
disponible en librairie et sur sur
Internet merci beaucoup Lauren lubbanza
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation pour
plus d'informations sur votre actualité
votre livre on peut également se rendre
sur votre Tik Tok Lauren luganza et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]